you know food insecurity is a big
concern in the valley we've talked about
it a lot families are being forced to
make a lot of tough choices to make ends
meet well that's especially true for
families who terminally ill children and
today a local non-profit is working to
meet their needs and give them one less
thing to worry about Candace Charles
joining us live from Albertsons near
Blue Diamond and Decatur to explain how
it works good morning
good morning YouTube good morning folks
listen here's what I want you to do
Saturday and Sunday you can go to the
Albertsons on West Charleston and Sloan
and look for this van or you can go to
the Albertsons right here on Blue
Diamond the following Saturday and
Sunday look for the van bring some items
and help fill up the truck to help it
look like this and it all benefits
angels of Las Vegas and I'm joined by
any she is the founder of angels Las
Vegas and really she has quite a story
of why she's decided to start this
wonderful charity that benefits
terminally ill children as well as
patients with cancer tell us about it
while you start to do this you know um
my family members one of my god sister
was going through cancer and the you
know help was in it was it was there for
us but it was like there's so much stuff
that needed for the caregivers and for
the wigs and for all the stuff is that's
why that I started this and by the
amazing team that I have and I'm so
grateful for our community partner
Albertson Vance so many our sponsors
97.8.5 and just been here helping us so
many people are volunteers that our team
is just grateful for us to take it from
where to start from 12 years ago to be
where we are right now the location that
we have the food pantry everything that
just I'm a Visionary I think of it I you
know plan it and it was out my team in
the community it wouldn't be what it is
right now and I'm so grateful for that
now I know you just started the pantry
about a year ago and I know it takes
time to fill it up you've had some folks
helping you but how does this food drive
help I mean this is the first time you
guys are doing and you've already seen
people come to the first two events how
will it help you guys this is going to
help so much because once we start
giving out the food and we you know it's
taking pictures and people start talking
and more people are coming and sometimes
we didn't have the food to give up to
give back so we have to go out and buy
the food and just so every week is more
and more families in need and I'm like
we were worried because what are we
going to give out so by starting this
food drive it's gonna be this is amazing
this is going to help so much because
now that we have more to give and this
is we're going to keep continue doing
this especially in Holiday Time and it's
so so important and I'm very very
grateful for this and now we're not
worried about every time Tuesday comes
we're like oh my God how are we gonna do
this and everybody email us and text us
how many family you're gonna help so now
we're so excited and just to see the
smile on the Family's face is amazing
thank you so much for the work you do
and thank you for chatting with us this
morning now they're helping more than
200 families and you have a chance to
help out as well I said it earlier you
can come to the Albertsons on West
Charleston and Sloan this Saturday and
Sunday next Saturday and Sunday you come
to this Albertsons off of Blue Diamond
bring some items something healthy to
help out these families very simple to
do now I have those details for you on
our website
8newsnow.com for now live from
Albertsons on Blue Diamond I'm Candice
Charles 8 news now all right Candace
thank you very much it's a great
organization great cause great to help
out